I'm William Zaluga
and this is a
discussion of the
pathology of skin tumors
for P-POM-1. Here's
my information.
I'm in Arkansas
in Wilson Hall. If
you're here, just
give me a call or come
to the office or
send me an email.
Here are the
objectives. We're going
to talk about
benign conditions.
Here's some listed
conditions that are
pre-malignant like
actinic keratosis.
Then, malignant
disorders of the
epithelium and
melanocytic cells.
And here is a listing
of the different types
of conditions that
we're going to discuss.
It'll give you a good
idea of the kind of
epithelial tumors that
occur in the skin.
Starting with benign lesion,
SKs or seborrheic keratoses,
as you can see I've
outlined the different
kind of characteristics
associated with this,
important is to know
is that occurs in a
certain demographic
group, middle age, older,
and they appear stuck
on like you can peel
them off and I have
a picture shown here.
And while this is benign,
conditions may be
associated with
certain disorder,
other disorders that
may produce some
neoplastic potential.
For example, the
lesser Trilat sign is a
paraneoplastic syndrome where
there is a rapid increase
in the number of these
SKs and it could be
a marker of other types
of cancers and there's
an activating mutation
associated with the
discovery of many of these
SKs in that condition
okay so the SK the biopsy
is done what you'll see is
the epithelium and that
there's a lot of cells that
look like basal cells, cells
with darker, slightly larger
nuclei, not as much cytoplasm
as the more superficial
cells, so these would be
considered Basilar type
cells and they proliferate
throughout the epithelium.
There's a lot of keratin
production, known as
hyperkeratosis, and you can
see that at surface how keratin
is represented but you can
also see the imagination
of some of these keratin
nodules forming what's called
keratin-filled cysts or
horn cysts and you see many
of them throughout here okay
on the acanthosis nigricans
and i have a clinical
picture on the next slide
So, the description
is thickened,
hyperpigmented regions
of skin, usually
in the flexural
regions of the body.
And increased growth
factors are thought
to be a cause of
this development.
And the important
thing about it is it
might be an important
continuous sign of
underlying benign and
malignant conditions.
Benign conditions are most
commonly associated with
this, 80%, and those are
usually occurring in younger
individuals and associated
with diabetes and obesity.
Older individuals, it is
more of a paraneoplastic
phenomenon, and
there could be an
underlying adenocarcinoma
often of the GI system.
And here's what it would
look like, and if you took
a biopsy, what you would
see characteristically is
thickened dermal papulae
between these reedy ridges, and
there's undulating with
lots of peaks and valleys.
Okay, you can see that
on this biopsy specimen.
The basal cell layer does
show hyperpigmentation,
but there's no
melanocyte hyperplasia.
Epithelial polyps
are extraordinarily
common, also known as
skin tags, acrochordon,
squamous papilloma.
They occur in middle-aged
older individuals and there's
a histologic section that
I know I don't have that.
If you did do a biopsy
of one of these what you
would see is that there's
a thin stalk and that
would be the pyrovascular
core and that's going
to be covered with benign
squamous epithelium.
Sometimes these
are associated with
diabetes, obesity,
and intestinal polyps,
multiple intestinal
polyps that develop,
all called
intestinal polyposis,
and can become
numerous in pregnancy,
thought to be due to hormones.
A WAN is a nodule that can
occur due to imagination
and cystic expansion of the
epidermis, more commonly
involving a hair follicle.
It's well circumscribed
and movable as you can
see in this photograph.
It's going to be flesh-colored.
If it's not movable, then
you might think something
else like an invasive type
of cellular proliferation.
It might be more
worrisome, but this is
movable, flesh-colored,
and histopathology shown in
the lower image shows, once
again, a keratin-filled
cyst with benign epithelium
surrounding that.
There are subtypes,
and the subtypes are
named according to what
the wall resembles.
So epithelial shows
normal epidermis, pilar or
trachelemal is a hair
follicle epithelium, dermoid
multiple appendages and
spacious steatocystomas.
AKs are a transition
between a benign condition
and something that
might become malignant.
It is a premalignant
epithelial tumor and in this
lower image you can see
how that looks and how this
occurs is usually from UV
radiation. So you You'll
find it on sun-damaged
skin areas, and what you'll
see if the biopsy is done
is squamous dysplasia.
These often appear
as multiple lesions,
and the people
more at risk than
others are likely
pigmented individuals.
Sometimes there's going to
be so much keratin produced
by these lesions that the
top image shows what's
called a cutaneous horn,
and if you look at it
histologically, it actually
resembles the horns of animals.
Clinically, these are small,
flesh-colored, and they
have a rough consistency
like sandpaper when
they're palpated.
Just pathologically, what
you see is cell atypia,
okay,
so enlarged cells are
seen in the basal layer
with irregular nuclear
contours that are becoming
more angulated. there's
hyperchromasia the nuclei
appear darker and you
also see hyperkeratosis
and you can see more
keratin being produced here.
Parakeratosis if you
look closely here you can
see nuclei still
retained in the stratum
corneum layer where
there's not supposed to be
nuclei after the granular
cell layer down here.
So that's an abnormal finding.
Solar elastosis, normally this
material appears
pink in the subcutis,
but due to UV damage, it'll
look blue-gray because
of damage to the
fibroblasts that are are
producing irregular
collagen and elastin fibers.
So those are well-known
precursors to squamous cell
carcinoma, and they can
develop over months to years.
One important thing is that
you see that that atypia
that I was describing
earlier of those cells, so
I'll go back, these
atypical cells down here in
the basal layer, sometimes
they they're extending
fairly high into the
superficial epidermis. If that
becomes full thickness,
then that's known as in
-situ squamous cell carcinoma.
But if it's confined
to the epidermis, then
it's called in-situ as long
as it doesn't break through
the basement membrane.
Squamous cell
carcinoma is common.
Older people are affected
more than younger.
And that's because of
the progressive DNA
damage caused by UV
exposure in individuals.
As before,
lightly pigmented
individuals are
at more risk for
this condition.
But it's not just UV exposure.
There's also many other
conditions and toxins that
can produce, are associated
with squenic cell carcinoma.
And the only reason I
know about these is because
there were cases that were
reported after these exposures,
and UV radiation maybe
not was one of the most
important things for those
individuals, like oral cavity
and tobacco association.
If people are immunosuppressed
for whatever reason,
they have an increased risk
of squamous cell carcinoma.
There's a low rate
of invasion and
metastasis, so a fairly
good prognosis. Okay,
histopathology is
described here, but
first a little bit
about the pathogenesis.
P53 dysfunction is supposed
to repair your DNA.
In AK, if there's
dysfunction of that,
then any mutations in
the DNA can be passed
on to daughter cells
that are produced.
so this could be an early
event where this genetic
abnormality leads to the
pathway of becoming a malignant
lesion clinical findings
you'll see once again a
lot of hyper keratosis and
something called keratin
pearls I'll show you
intercellular bridges and these
two that I highlighted are
features that you would
look for if you're looking
to diagnose what that that
tumor is sometimes these
tumors may be so dysplastic
that they are termed what's
called anaplastic but
cells don't look like they're
making one type of tissue
or another and they just
look like sheets or cords
of abnormal malignant
cells but if you look for
keratin pearls and intracellular
bridges, then you'll
be able to determine that
those are squamous cells that
you're dealing with in a
squamous cell carcinoma.
And this is what that
can look like grossly.
You'll see something that
looks like an AK with a scale
crust on the surface, but
they can become nodular.
And those more nodular
lesions, those more
nodular lesions are
going to be the more
advanced kind of lesion,
especially if the
ulceration of a lesion
starts to occur.
And as you can see, they
can occur on the skin and
also mucosal surfaces, as
seen in this photograph. The
blue outlines that you
see here are demonstrating
some of the features that
you would see with an in situ
lesion. So you do see full
thickness dysplasia of the
cells as they progress
upward with hyperchromasia,
angular nuclei,
and lack of maturation.
These cells are supposed to
get smaller as they progress
towards the grain of
their cell layer, and then
they lose their nuclei, but
these are the large cells
that are proliferating.
But it's confined to
the basement membrane.
If you look closely, you
can see a pale pink line
at the base of the
epithelium here, and that's
the basement membrane,
so it hasn't invaded yet.
So this would be
inside the lesion.
Here what you'll see are
intracellular bridges. So
those are the connections,
desmosomes, between the
keratinocytes here. If you
look at the nuclei, those
are dysplastic nuclei, and
they're connected by these
bridges so that it's of
squamous origin. And so do
these keratin pearls, which
are just swirling modules
of keratin produced in
the wrong areas, in this
case, within an evading
tumor rather than keratin
being produced at the surface
of the epithelium. Now,
nasal cell carcinoma is a
locally aggressive tumor,
important to know, it's
very slow-growing, rarely
metastasizes, and it's
the most common cancer in
humans, and the most common
invasive cancer in humans.
It's pathogenesis
is involved with
activation of the hedgehog
signaling pathway.
And this pathway
becomes activated
through DNA damage
caused by UV exposure.
So lightly pigmented
individuals are
going to be more
effective, and also if
you have some form
of immunosuppression.
Clinically,
this is important.
They look like pearly,
waxy papules, often with
telangiectasias, or dilated
blood vessels on the surface
that you can see through the
surface of the skin there.
They have rolled borders, too.
Sometimes they can become
centrally ulcerated
if they're going for a
long time, but that's
less common than that
squamous cell or snowman.
So if you look histopathologically
at this lesion,
you'll see tumor cells
that resemble basal layer.
They form nodular lesions
and they can infiltrate
into the dermis.
There's something called
peripheral palisade in
which I'll show you in just
a moment. This is a
pathogenesis and treatment.
So there's mutations that
activate the hedgehog pathway
and And there's loss of
function of this receptor,
patch 1, that's the
receptor for Sonic Hedgehog.
And that caused an
increase in this
transcription factor,
GLI-1, and tumor growth.
This tumor is associated
with a syndrome
that's caused by a patch
mutation called Gorlin
syndrome, and that
causes an increased
incidence of multiple
basal cell carcinomas.
And treatment is going to
be removed by surgery or
cryotherapy, and there are
some topical treatments that
will help with reducing the
growth of these tumors so as
I was saying here are the
telangiectasias and it appears
as a pearly nodule one of
the histologic features
you'll see that will help
you with your diagnosis is
you have these nodules of
tumor that invaded into the
subcutaneous tissues and
upon sectioning there's going
to be retraction of that
tissue from the surrounding
stroma seen here and it looks
like fibromucinous stroma.
Mucins will have this
grayish appearance and lots
of fibrous tissue as
well and you see a lot of
lymphocytes too but there's
going to be a retraction
artifact around the actual
nodule of tumor cells.
You can see here what's
known as the peripheral
palisade. Okay, so the tumor
cells are going to align
on their long axis in
parallel with each other.
Kind of like the boards
or logs on old forts
or ramparts, those are
known as palisades.
Dynocytic tumors include
many many different kinds of
benign tumors and we'll
talk about a couple of them.
A couple of them you know
these first two and then
get into this plastic nevi
which are showing atypical
features that might signal
malignant change and then
melanoma which is malignancy
of those melanocytic
cells okay start with solar
okay solar lentigo solar
lentigo a quick overview
it's a benign localized
hyperplasia of melanocytes
it's not precancerous and
they generally do not
progress and they occur on sun
exposed areas typically older
individuals older adults
and increased prevalence
and lightly pigmented
individuals usually small and
tan brown I have a picture
on the next slide that
will show you that they can
be on the skin or oral mucosa
and one essential feature
is that they are linear
along the just above the
basement membrane so in
the basal layer and they're
not and they're not nested
They're not forming clusters
of melanocytes that are
undergoing hyperplasia.
Okay.
And that's known as a
lentiginous growth pattern.
Sometimes you'll see
a lentiginous growth
pattern in some kinds
of melanoma, and I list
those here, but that's
not what solar lentico
is. This is just
describing growth just
above the dermal
-epidermal junction. Here's
what they look like on
sun-exposed areas of
the hand. And you see
a proliferation of
these melanocytes just
in the basal cell air.
Other features that you'll
find are dermal papulate
that will be enlarged, and
the reedy ridges will be
thin and extended in this
kind of condition as well.
Down here you see what
looks like melanin
pigmentation within
cells and these cells are
macrophages that are
engulfing melanin that has
spilled out from this
hyperplastic material here.
While these hyperplastic
cells are producing this
material and the macrophages
are specialized cells
that are engulfing it,
those known as melanophages.
Okay, now we're going to talk
about moles or
melanocytic nevi.
They can be congenital or
acquired, they're
usually small.
So they'll be smaller
than what is typically
seen when we were
looking at a malignant
melanoma, usually smaller
than six millimeters.
And this will be important,
they're symmetric, they
have uniform colors and
smooth borders, and we'll
learn later about the ABCDEs
of melanoma, but these are
symmetric, uniform, and
smooth borders, and small.
70% have a BRAF
or RAS mutation,
so important to remember.
So, you might wonder
why that is not
not leading to that
becoming a malignant
tumor because of
those mutations.
Well,
normally when you have
activated RAS or BRAF in
human melanocytes, this
causes only a limited period
of that proliferation and
then you have permanent
growth arrest and And
that's mediated by
accumulation of proteins
such as P16, INK4A, which are
inhibitors of several
cyclin-dependent kinases.
So that produces growth of
the rest, and that provides
protection and prevents the
development of melanoma.
Here are some representative
variant forms of these moles.
You can have a
congenital one. As you
can see, they can
be flat or raised.
So, congenital ones are
going to be present at
birth, and melanoma
can rarely develop,
especially if it's a large
congenital nevus, but
rarely does that melanoma
develop within that.
A blue nevus looks blue
because of a localized
proliferation of dermal
melanocytes, so below the layer
of the epithelium, and you
have melanocytes that are
proliferating. A spitz nevus
looks like a humangioma
and is common in children
and often noted for its
rapid growth, but it will
usually regress on its own.
Halo nevus is due to an
autoimmune response to surrounding
melanocytes at the dermal
-epidermal junction,
and the halo is produced
by that autoimmune reaction
against those melanocytes.
It can be a harbinger of
vitiligo, so that might be
a condition that this person
may be developing if you
find this. And then there's
this plastic nevis. So this
is a progression from being
benign to potentially a
pre-cancerous lesion. So
those are known as atypical
nevi, potential indicator
of future melanoma, and what
you'll find is cytologic
atypia and nesting of
melanocytes within the dermis.
So, first we'll go over
the normal maturation
sequence of non-dysplastic
melanocytic nevi, or moles.
Normally, what you'll
see is a collection of
melanocytes within the
basal layer, and they're
going to make melanin
and transfer it over
to other keratinocytes
within the basal layer.
As they mature, you'll
see a proliferation
of some of these melanocytes,
and they'll form clusters
along the dermal epidermal
junction okay as they
continue to mature these
cells will transfer from the
dermal epidermal junction
downward into the dermis
and as you can see in
this diagram it's indicating
the cells are becoming
smaller and the nuclei in
the cells are all becoming
smaller that's known as
maturation in this case
this has mature to
become a dermal nebus or
intradermal nebus and the
final stage of this maturation
will be small melanocytes
and they will become wavy
with very nondistinct
nuclei and that's known as
neurotization that's
just a feature of their
maturation that's the normal
way that they develop okay
so this would be your
junctional nebus this is at
the dermal epidermal
junction you'll see clusters
of these melanocytes at
that junction you see the
basement membrane layer
right here surrounding all
of those okay and those
will be flat because within
the epidermis if they become
dermal or parts partly
normal this is junctional
you can see here and uh
this is interdermal melanocytes
they could be raised
or nodded or like this
and this one here this
is an intradermal nevus
entirely within the dermis.
And the way you would
determine if these are
nevuses is that you would
look at the cells, make
sure there's no atypia,
and they're following the
normal growth patterns
that I just described.
So dysplastic
nevus, we're going
to talk about
that last one now,
an overview.
That's a potential precursor.
Most never progress, but
there's an increased risk
with an increased number
of these dysplastic nearby.
So what you have is a disorder
proliferation of
atypical melanocytes.
Once again, UV radiation
is going to be one of the
factors that's going to
be damaging the DNA and
causing this potential
for malignancy to develop.
So you'll find it on
exposed skin and lightly
pigmented individuals
will have a higher risk.
They often carry the BRAF
and RAS mutations and a loss
of function of CDKN2A,
which is a tumor suppressor.
There is an autosomal
dominant form, which
can be transmitted
genetically, which
forms multiple dysplastic
mevi and melanoma.
And this is that picture
I just showed you.
They're going to be
typically larger than the
acquired nearby okay ones
occur on sun exposed areas
they're larger they can
be flat or raised and have
variable pigmentation so
that's different from what
we were just describing
so here you can see here
it's more dark brown here
it's a bit lighter here
it's taking more of a pink
color so that's abnormal
and it has irregular borders
okay if you cut it in
half does this half look
like that one If not, then
that's going to be in a
regular order that you
need to be worried about
the growth of this lesion.
If you do a biopsy, what you
can see is cellular atypia.
So these cells are going
to have irregular shapes.
The nuclei are not going
to be the same sizes or
shapes. They're going
to be darker, so they're
going to be hyperchromatic.
and you'll have enlarged
nuclei and a prominent
what's called a nucleolus.
You can't see it on
this image right here,
but the nucleolus on
this is where a lot
of the protein
synthesis is occurring,
and those can be
really prominent in
these cells that are
growing very rapidly.
One thing you see here is
some of the characteristic
features of a dysplastic
knee bite, such as fibrosis,
shown here in the green
arrow, and you can see this
pink material is collagen
that's being produced between
these reed ridges. okay
you'll see bridging of these
melanocyte clusters so from
this reedy ridge you'll see
extension all the way from
to this reedy ridge and
then all the way over to
this one so bridging will be
one of the features of a
dysplastic anepi that's a
characteristic of abnormal
maturation and growth or also
known as architectural
disorder one of the features of
malignancy or potential
for malignancy and then
there's melanocyte incontinence
and I went over that
before but you can see
some of this here some of
the melanophages that I'm
pointing to will have that
brown pigment within the
cytoplasm and lymphocytic
infiltrates and I circled
the blue circle shows
some of the lymphocytes
these small dark nuclei
without a lot of cytoplasm
so we got lymphocytes all
throughout the superficial
dermis of this lesion.
And that would
help you determine
that's a dysplastic nevus.
Okay, now moving from there
to melanoma, as you can
see we already talked about
these mutations and you
can see some of those in
dysplastic nevus. Well as you
acquire more and because
of more damage usually
caused by UV radiation then
that can progress to an
invasive tumor called
melanoma it's got the highest
mortality of all skin cancers
most are cured by surgery
and one of the only
important features to be pay
attention to is the depth of
invasion and whether or not
metastases have occurred
because that'll determine
the prognosis so early
detection is crucial obviously
thin lesions that haven't
metastasized those of them
have the best prognosis
there's the ABCD ease of
melanoma that we've gone
over a little bit A is for
asymmetrical B is for borders
irregular C is for color
variegated difficulty D is
for diameter usually larger
greater than six military
is for evolution rapidly
progressing over time and
here is what it looks like
in photographs so this
would be your Bani mole and
your melanoma you can see
the asymmetry the regular
borders you can see different
colors in these lesions
you can see the diameter
is bigger than this mole
over here and it's evolving
here this may be a short
period of time from this
photograph here to this one.
So those would be concerning.
So there's two distinct
periods of growth of
melanoma, radial growth
and vertical growth. Okay,
and that occurs because
of the the introduction of
lesions to the DNA that
cause a progressive irregular
growth. So first you'll
have radial growth where the
tumors will start to form
mass and they'll look atypical
and as they spread some
of them might escape past
the basement membrane but
they're still being held
together and proliferating
along the basement membrane
and then e-cat-heron could
become a loss. E-cat-heron
is a protein that helps
bind these cells together.
Once that loss then these
tumor cells will have the
liberty to migrate on their
own as you can see here
instead of forming cluster
here and then maturing
appropriately down into
the dermis these cells are
migrating upward okay and
they're not that's a sign
of abnormal growth so
with loss of ehen here and
you get that abnormal growth
and then here it shows
rupture through the
basement membrane and these
cells gaining access
to the vasculature so
this is known as the
vertical growth phase when
the basement membrane
becomes breached and then
the tumor cells can gain
proximity to lymph and
blood vessels and that
has a poor prognosis.
This radial growth
phase as the tumor cells
are acquiring this mutation
can remain for months
to years before there's
the final hit and
it'll develop that ability
to break through of
the basal membrane and
possibly metastasize.
Here's the major types,
major subtypes of melanomas.
There's going to be
superficial spreading.
And what you'll notice
here is that the ones that
have the good prognosis
are going to be associated
with a long radial growth
phase. I just told you
it can last from months
to years. And these ones
have a long radial growth
phase. Then there's a
nodular melanoma. They
have rapid rate of growth
and very early vertical
growth base, so poor
prognosis. There's something
called agro-lentigenous
melanoma. It's most common
of non-white individuals
and occurs on the soles
and palms and sub-ungual
regions of the body, and it
has early vertical growth.
And poor prognosis, commonly
due to delayed recognition
as being a melanoma, and
that's what that would look
like, aquilantiginous, and
this brown streak, and you
can see it spilling over
into the periungal region.
And all of these, if
you remember, your A,
B, C, D, E's are a
very great concern for
melanoma, just by
looking at the image.
So, histopathologically, the
biopsies done what you'll
see is very abnormal growth
of these nests of melanoma
you can see these melanoma
cells they're large
they're angulated some of
them will have nucleolide but
also they're single cells
that you can see here and
they're migrating upwards
okay it's not supposed to
do that so that's abnormal
growth abnormal architecture
down here you can see
these individual cells have
broken through the basement
membrane and there's this
brisk exuberant lymphocytic
infiltrate. It's
perivascular and also along
the dermal-epidermal junction.
Pacitoid spread refers
to the spread of
these cells within the
epidermis, but along
the basement membrane
and also spreading more
superficially into
the epidermis as well.
And pacitoid comes
from the disease known
as Paget disease of
the breast, where
those cells will show
this kind of pattern.
If you see mitoses of these
cells within the dermis,
that's a sign that those
cells are not maturing
properly, they're actually
dividing within the
dermis rather than becoming
smaller and undergoing
neurotization and maturing
in the appropriate way.
So, how is it diagnosed?
You have to do a biopsy
and determine what's the
depth of invasion, and
that can be difficult,
especially if there's
ulceration. So, all types
of invasion and ulceration
are noted in reports
that will determine what
the stage of those lesions
are for your patients.
A sentinel lymph node
biopsy is often done, and a
sentinel lymph node is going
to be the lymph node that's
going to receive the lymph
fluid from the primary
tumor most directly okay
and sometimes if these
tumors are very dysplastic
almost anaplastic it might
be difficult to say that
that is a melanoma and
immunohistochemical staining
may need to be done so
there's genetic testing because
if you find some certain
BRAC disorder that could
be a target for therapy,
okay?
So, prognosis is based
on the Breslow depth, as
I already mentioned, and
here's how you measure
that. You got to use a
microscope and whether
there's metastases, so you
have to use a microscope
to make sure that there's
none in any of the
other lymph nodes or the
tissues that you get.
You're going to be
checking for mitotic rate,
ulceration, and a tumor
infiltrating lymphocytes.
Here is what's called TNM
cancer staging system,
and this is for melanoma.
It's different for
many different kinds
of tissues and lesions.
So as you can see, Reslow
depth is going to be important.
That's going to be part
of your staging system.
Melanomas are graded,
you know, what they look
like, but the staging
system is much more
descriptive of what
the prognosis for your
patients will be with a
condition like melanoma.
So,
thin tumors have the best
prognosis, you know, and
then progressively worse
as they become thicker.
Greater than 4 millimeters
is going to be about
37 to 50% survival rate
because those thicker
lesions have a higher
incidence of metastases.
and that's what your TNM
system is showing you
here. Stage 0 is in situ.
It's just confined to the
epidermis. Stage 1 and
2 is locally invasive.
But there's no
spread to the lymph
nodes. So T1 through
T4 are describing
the thickness, as
you can see up here.
No lymph node metastasis and
no other distant metastasis.
Here, stage 3, then you
start to get into metastasis.
So,
the lymph nodes are more
proximal to the lesion.
If that occurs, then the
survival drops quite a bit,
down to 35% by your survival.
And with this metastasis,
it's even worse. So, that's
what the M stands for.
Treatments are going to be
excision, usually known as
wide local excision, and
what's going to be evaluated
when those are excised and
examined is the tumor itself
and what's known as margins,
and you want the margins
or edges of the tissue
that's removed to be clear,
clean, negative, it's been
described different ways, and
that just indicates that
the surgeon might remove all
the tumor, so the risk of
recurrence there is minimal.
You have to evaluate
the sentinel lymph nodes
and another way of treating
these tumors which is
newer and exciting kinds
of therapy are checkpoint
inhibitors and what
those do is enhance T
cell mediated anti-tumor
responses and I put some
examples of the kinds
of monoclonal antibody
solutions that they're using.
Also, if you have a patient
that you discovered,
you can do genetic testing
and phylogenetic mutation
of BRAF V600E, because that
drives melanoma growth,
then there's some BRAF
inhibitors that might be
able to use to help people
with those conditions.
And thank you. This is
the feedback form, so
please send me feedback.
I'd really appreciate it.
And best of luck with all
your studies. Bye. Thank you.